I think modern parenting over the last
20 years has softened so dramatically
that many parents are mad at Tick Tock
and Instagram and social media without
realizing they have 100 control of
deleting it off their child's phone they
have 100 control of taking their child's
phone away for a month if they choose to
so guiding my children for me it's
actually paying attention and caring to
what they're consuming I think parenting
in 2023 has become too passive has been
too conducive to being your kid's friend
instead of your kid's parent and I would
argue that until we get back to full
accountability we will continue to blame
politics a mainstream media social media
Tick Tock Facebook Mark and we're
blaming and we're blaming yet every
parent that's watching this right now
has control because they're the parent
so my point of view on this is parents
need to step up in a significant way be
willing to be inconvenienced of their
child being upset with them and actually
parent